Francia va a adoptar más o menos la
misma política copiar lo que está
haciendo china en África no se mete
prácticamente en la política interna de
África no van a promover lo que es la
democracia como tal sino tratar de como
meterse como para evitar que nos dicen
que Francia es como oto colonizador es
otro que viene a dar órdenes yo creo que
este discurso los africanos mismo lo
toman con mucho
con mucho como
precaución con mucho duda sobre la
verdadera intención de Francia en este
Nueva Era que él está descubriendo allí
y en su opinión Cuál es el nivel de
conciencia expresado por el presidente
Manuel macrón del recelo y de este
escepticismo que genera en ciertas
sociedades africanas digamos la
influencia francesa tal como le
preguntaba una periodista de la
televisión de gabón
la influencia francesa está allí pero el
problema es que los africanos Por
ejemplo si uno mira los grandes
capitales están llegando a África
actualmente pero todo esto es como una
batalla de sobre todo para influenciar a
los africanos lo que está pasando en la
ONU con Ucrania todo esto la influencia
francesa
no es como Sobre todo como si fuera una
patenaria que están buscando con África
sino es como dar una respuesta a la
influencia de Rusia da una respuesta a
la influencia de China no es tal como
tal que van a empezar una nueva relación
con África por tener una relación con
África sino es contra el estar es como
si fuera que usted viene acá en África
para hacer algo no para los africanos
sino para replantear mi posición desde
hace en África para plantearme en al
frente de mis competidores Claro porque
en relación a esto que está comentando
no macron ha dicho al inicio de la
conferencia que quería dejar de lado
este juego de competición de
competencias por la influencia en África
pero después minutos más tarde ha
señalado Cómo quiere ayudar a la Unión
Europea a situarse en influir ámbitos
como decíamos como los que está ocupando
China o Rusia en términos de
infraestructura o de defensa también ha
señalado que no quiere ser la cabeza de
Turco de los problemas que hay en África
Entonces mi pregunta es realmente
macron lo que estaría buscando sería
compartir la responsabilidades de su
influencia y esas consecuencias con la
Unión Europea Más allá de abandonar esta
competencia
exactamente combatirlo porque Italia
todo Alemania Albania por ejemplo lo que
es como en defensa cuando se trata de
vender armas todo estas como como
operaciones internacionales que está
proponiendo él como África como África
es como si fuera el patio de Francia
entonces la Unión Europea tiene entendía
que depender mucho de Francia para esta
para esta colaboración para esa
penetración África para esta nueva era
para esa Nueva Era que Francia quiere
plantear en África pero tomando el
liderazgo por ser como por la misma
personalidad que tiene Francia en África